four people are dead after two planes  crashed into each other at north las  vegas airport this was the scene on  sunday afternoon the federal aviation  administration says a single engine  piper pa-46 and a single-engine cessna  172 collided on the runway as one was  preparing to land two people were on  each plane and they lost their lives the  piper crashed into a field the cessna  caught fire and fell into a water  retention pond  my flight instructor indicated that she  knows the couple that owns the piper  meridian i have my plane hangard here  and  there's a lot of traffic so it's always  a concern about you know how well the  airport system and  flights are managed coming in and out of  the airport  names of those involved have not been  released air traffic at the airport  resumed a short time later